[Música]
a gente depois que você mora quase 14
anos na austrália se aprende que tem
muito mais que cangurus coalas e surfar
lá na verdade você vê que tem
descobertas como caixa preta do avião
marcapasso ouvido biônico válvula dupla
para vasos sanitários para economia de
água e para alguns sortudos como eu eles
também inventaram como armazenar vinho
em barris de carvalho pra você incluir
aí pra vocês terem uma ideia são mais de
10 prêmios nobel naquele país um país de
22 milhões de habitantes como se são
paulo tivesse 12 prêmios nobel só para
ter uma idéia de como a dimensão de
pesquisas e descobertas fazem parte
desse desse cenário né na austrália e é
nesse cenário que eu trago à vocês a
história de um jovem um excelente
estudante de matemática que viu seus
sonhos desmoronar porque ele foi
diagnosticado com dislexia e teve que
abandonar os estudos
esse cara ele mora numa cidade chamada
chatbi vocês viram o tamanho do
aeroporto shark bay é um único ponto
mais noroeste da austrália uma cidade
com 600 habitantes
chatbi é longe de tudo né são 400
quilômetros para você chegar até um
cheque bem
ela fica parecendo que é uma cidade mais
bem estruturada você não chega lá e
falar o seu quadro favor pegue um
segunda rua errada vir para aqui shakira
não acontece já que 400 km de distância
da cidade melhor e é por isso que esse
rapaz ele não tem muito recurso não é
pra onde trabalhar
ele foi trabalhar na fazenda de ostras
da família um trabalho que merece muita
dedicação não é um trabalho que merece é
você tá ficando e sol forte
na ocasião um é já perderam tudo várias
vezes porque eu uma enfermidade grave do
seu pai o uma outra ocasião são
tempestades e até doença da fazenda de
outra que assolam
a região de tempos em tempos né ele
percebeu que a mesma dificuldade que ele
tinha ler pode ser disléxica ele tinha
uma facilidade o cérebro dele pensava
diferente ao ler haver reações químicas
imagine se a gente tivesse o dom de
todos os dias o olhar uma reação química
de forma clara volta de morgan tinha e
tem esse dom
mesmo sem ter nenhum ensino ensino
formal
robert ele descobriu uma forma de uma
parafina 11 um derivado do petróleo um
dos poluentes mais terríveis no mundo se
lamentado o nano minerais fossem um dos
elementos pra tratamento de água e
efluentes não percebeu que a caa a placa
de parafina era a casa ideal para que as
bactérias que já estão no meio benéficas
crescerem ao redor dela
vocês podem ver no vidro lippi mágoa
antes de tratar e depois de ser tratada
que é uma forma e vem sendo estudado e
tem sido comprovada como as melhores
formas de tratamento hídrico no mundo as
maiores descobertas e como ela funciona
vamos partir de um corpo de água sujo
tá ao inserirmos a tecnologia na água
ela começa de forma exponencial
multiplicar as bactérias benéficas que
já estão no meio fazendo esse trabalho
certo então na primeira semana ela dobra
vai multiplicar exponencialmente e vai
consumindo as a carga orgânica que tem
dentro do corpo hídrico
dessa forma que acontece essa
bioestimulação ela acaba entrando
deixando o meio e equilíbrio porque como
como acaba a sujeira carga orgânica ea
bactéria se alimenta de burro de carga
orgânica o meio fio e equilíbrio porque
ela morre de inanição
isso é um processo natural que ocorre
quando falei potencial agente policial
mesmo
porque olha só você tem geralmente numa
uma ação bacteriana benéfica como essa
que nós estamos falando você tem as
bactérias dobram 8 mil vezes a cada
quase uma hora com a tecnologia de
robert morgan
elas crescem mas dobram 8 milhões de
vezes a cada 26 minutos tudo usando um
dos elementos principais
o derivado do petróleo para a final
vocês terem uma idéia essa foto aqui a
foto da esquerda o balde mais escuro ela
é derivada de um lacinho nasce de búfala
que tem uma carga orgânica muito mais
forte que a bovina muita proteína muita
gordura e do lado direito você já vê a
água tratada com a tecnologia do roberto
depois de 22 horas
a água ficou com 98.200 tratamento que
hoje é usada tanto para reuso ou se ela
quisesse jogar devolvida à no rio e isso
demonstra a vocês a rapidez que é a de
um sucesso que a tecnologia do rock né
hoje essa tecnologia vem sendo usado em
mais de dez países
e ela pode ser usada em diferentes
aplicabilidade dela pode ser usado em
diferentes meios como por exemplo
fazenda de camarão por exemplo você tem
uns tanques densos com muito camarão
camarão animal muito sensível né
então se você mudar a temperatura se ela
tiver muito suja o que acontece mas têm
uma mortalidade muito alta você tem um
prejuízo na sua produtividade com a
tecnologia do robert
o mesmo princípio que eu expliquei antes
ao colocar a tecnologia no tanque
as bactérias que consome a sujeira
consomem a carga orgânica água fica mais
limpa - morte de camarão maior
produtividade
então é uma das formas que a gente
naquele eles trabalham lá frigoríficos
laticínios bebidas alcoólicas fabrica a
bebida alcoólica água e esgoto tudo isso
é feito usando essa tecnologia
robert ano trouxe recentemente robert
ele desafiou a comunidade acadêmica
dizendo o seguinte a barragem certas
barragens açudes e lagoas
elas têm toxinas como tem muito
nutriente ali certas toxinas que são
letais aos mamíferos
ela se alimenta de espécies nutrientes
só que roberto falou gente isso talvez
esteja errado e chamou a atenção de um
do instituto nun 1977 a prova na
austrália chamada belle machão que é em
nome do do prêmio nobel em medicina 2005
acho que chamou a atenção não só pelas
promessas afirmações mas para outras
afirmações e colocações que o roberto
fez tá mesmo não tendo voltando não
tenham ensino formal mas de novo ele vê
as coisas de forma diferente
o cérebro dele pensa de forma diferente
e ele chamou a atenção do instituto que
hoje é um dos parceiros do robert e em
estudo em estudar de forma mais
elaborada
aaaah sua tecnologia que inclusive pra
você ter uma idéia da magnitude da
descoberta do robert
hoje ela está sendo usada até na
agricultura na foto central tem uma
esfera que também é como se fosse um
pedaço dessa placa que eu acabei de
mostrar pra vocês é uma esfera que aos
ao receber um pouco de água gotejando
mento em cima dela ela já foi comprovado
que ela libera o fósforo na terra que é
um dos nutrientes né
os melhores 23 na medida certa óbvio da
agricultura então não só hoje está sendo
usado no corpo hídrico mas também na na
terra né
eu cuido descobrir essa tecnologia
netapp minha vida eu até brinco que o
meu corpo é paulista a alma carioca e o
coração australiano porque eu fiquei
determinado era o executivo
a educação como o pedro falou à
publicação internacional e eu mudei
totalmente a minha vida pra dedicar é a
disseminar esse tipo de tecnologia que
trazer para o brasil com a américa do
sul em não é porque eu tenho certeza
como ela pode ajudar a lavar as várias
pessoas aqui no brasil inclusive essa
tecnologia hoje está sendo usada junto à
fundação renova em minas gerais
como vocês devem lembrar em novembro de
2015 a nós tivemos aquele terrível
acidente em mariana minas gerais
aquela região já têm a carga presença de
metais pesados muito grande certo com o
acidente ela ficou ainda muito maior e
aí que essa placa entre porque na
austrália já foi testada já teve muito
sucesso em isolar os metais pesados no
corpo hídrico e deixando lhes inertes a
qualquer a população ou qualquer região
que ele tenha afetado
e aí que a nossa esperança e aí já
estamos testando essa tecnologia lá ea
idéia aqui é que consigamos de alguma
forma ajudar o corpo hídrico daquela
região ea população na redor
essa é o rio onde nós estamos a instalar
na placa é essa aí é é a placa que está
sendo colocada lá
essa foto é uma particularidade não por
acaso e mariana também gostava chama a
atenção de vocês que tem um rio e tem um
cano saindo ali da casa caído
diretamente no rio
isso não é de mariana do brasil e do
mundo 100 milhões de pessoas não têm
acesso a saneamento básico
aqui no brasil nós estamos falando de
estruturas primárias esgoto encanado
água de qualidade da água tratada a
qualidade de vida à tecnologia do do
roberto é apenas um exemplo
de tecnologias que tem um que possam ser
aplicada em larga escala que sejam
baratas que sejam eficazes que sejam de
fácil aplicação ea tecnologia dele um
exemplo só e eu acho que nos convida de
certa forma a gente ir além
a gente ia de coração e mente aberta
atrás dessas e de outras tecnologias
também né
porque são essas tecnologias que trazem
benefício para o povo para a população
em massa que a gente está aí e às vezes
atrás até do desafiador do contraditório
do paradoxal comum uma barra de parafina
derivados maiores poluentes do mundo
sendo usado para distribuir água
essa foto é isso eu lá em mariana em
minas gerais podem ver cheio de lama né
mas o coração de verdade cheia de
esperança foto é muito importante para
mim porque ela me fez refletir nessa
nesse momento eu tirei a foto onde
estava um ano e meio atrás atrás de um
escritório no ar condicionado no jardim
botânico no rio de janeiro e hoje eu
estava naquele momento uma forma
tentando fazer o meu melhor para ajudar
a as pessoas ela mariana para ajudar o a
natureza meio ambiente e me levou num
num fio assim de conexão com robert que
um cara que sai de uma cidade de 600
habitantes
acho que um prédio em copacabana tem
mais gente que lá em choque da i e ii e
como aquela aquela resiliência dele é
como aquele
a vontade dele a persistência mesmo
lugar sim lugar sem recursos
hoje eu estava do outro lado do mundo
tentando ajudar pessoas que nem conhece
talvez nem vai conhecer o óbvio mas eu
fiquei pensando no legado parceiro
roberto e talvez o legado do roberto não
seja nem a tecnologia
eu acho que o que deixou meu coração
cheio de esperança naquele momento foi
que talvez o maior legado do robert
ou seja enquanto nós tivemos todas as
razões para desistirmos que encontremos
uma a uma para seguir em frente porque
essa resiliência ela pode não apenas
ajudar você
mas no mundo contudo obrigado
[Aplausos]